all right i want to talk about your
character for a second both from the
books and the films kate blanchett
previously portraying
i know what it is you saw do you talk to
the actress do you reach out how does
something like this work for you um
i don't talk to cate blanchett but i
think about her all the time
well i play galadriel who's the lady of
light galadriel is someone who is has an
edge of danger about her because she is
a ring bearer i pass the test
i will diminish
and go into the west
and remain real honestly like those
films and who and adwin i was just so
obsessed with so it still
feels very surreal
it's like your character's really a
driving force in the series
the moment we feared
how would you describe where she kind of
is in the saga when we pick up
so
middle earth is experiencing a period of
peace but she doesn't believe it and so
she kind of is screaming into the void
um it's almost
in her own horror to a degree because
she feels there's something so dangerous
and no one is taking her seriously your
characters from both the books and the
films um with hugo weaving previously
portraying
you have only one choice
the ring must be destroyed
elrond is the fount of wisdom he has
this understanding about what has
happened so are you kind of predating
his performance how does it all work
well the show takes place thousands and
thousands of years before the lord of
the rings and so i focused a lot of my
research on
the first stage history
what came before
elrond
our days of peace
begin
when we pick up in the series where
where do we find your character in the
saga it's a sort of right-hand man to
the king really he's young and elf he is
so he's still learning you know he's not
a lord yet he's very interested in uh
different peoples of middle earth which
we we get to see a little bit of he's a
he's a seven you know it was in this
moment
when all hope had faded
that isildur son of the king took up his
father's sword
[Music]
your character specifically is a
complicated legacy in the books what can
you tell me when we pick up in the show
where's your character in the saga um
we obviously know where he ends
destroy it
there's definitely a weight of
expectation on my shoulders to to kind
of fulfill everyone's idea because they
have a sense of ownership over this
character they know what's happened we
find him at a bit of a crossroads he has
a strenuous relationship with his father
he wants to on one hand fulfill his
father's dream
and become a sea captain like him but
also there's like this deep yearning
for something else
it's a bit reckless
he may not make the right choices all
the time but i think he does it with a
lot of love and i think you can see a
lot of yourself in him if i can make if
i can make this guy relatable then maybe
you it would allow you to go on this
journey
of
of kind of tragic mistakes i guess for
the people that aren't familiar with
this series how how would you
simply describe this series i dare you
to describe it simply i think it's about
it's about friendship and bravery yeah
and
i think
you know everyone has the capacity for
evil and darkness
but there's always
shades of light
and i think this show really explores
that you know we're setting up a lot of
different worlds there's 21 characters
season regulars you know
but i think you'll that i think we all
color the world in our own specific way
and you'll fall in love with everyone
in your own way
[Music]